the United States has had
representatives working on this problem
for over 25 years they have done nothing
that's why we're in the problem that
we're in today in addition to frankly
other countries not doing what they
should have done tolerance for this
disgraceful practice must end now a new
order will give the Treasury Department
the discretion to sanction any foreign
bank that knowingly conducts or
facilitates significant transactions
tied to trade with North Korea and again
I want to just say and thank President
Xi of China for the very bold move he
made today that was a somewhat
unexpected move and we appreciate it
new authority in this area applies to
any activity that occurs following my
signature on the executive order which I
have actually just signed foreign banks
will face a clear choice to business
with the United States or facilitate
trade with the lawless regime in North
Korea and they won't have so much trade
this new order provides us with powerful
new tools but I want to be clear the
order targets only one country and that
country is North Korea